ever since the president misspoke on
Monday at the Helsinki summit the media
have spun around like whirling dervishes
their giddy with excitement excitement
of course that's masked info outrage
never has so much been made of so little
Dan Coates came to me and some others
they said they think it's Russia
I have President Putin he just said it's
not Russia I will say this I don't see
any reason why it would be now those
words set off a chain reaction of
condemnation without context you have
been watching perhaps one of the most
disgraceful performances by an American
president at a summit in front of a
Russian leader showing that I've ever
seen you should call this the surrender
summit oh so catchy former CIA director
John Brennan tweeted Donald Trump's
press conference performance in Helsinki
rises to and exceeds the threshold of
high crimes and misdemeanors it was
nothing short of treasonous John Brennan
says treasonous are we talking at least
from your perspective I assume from his
perspective impeachment well I'll let
that stand as it is as to the
responsibilities of the Congress the
United States
don't you miss Chuck Hagel by Monday
afternoon there were preposterous calls
for the CIA and National Intelligence
directors to resign in protest not
against the president's actions
substantive policies toward Russia but
resign over his comments at the press
conference should the Director of
National Intelligence Dan Coates resign
in protest
how does Gina Haskell stay on the job
how does Dan code stay on the duck by
Tuesday morning the media freak out was
evolving into totally uncharted
territory it was like the Bermuda
Triangle people who peddle Trump hatred
for a living and they make a good living
at it they tried to outdo one another
jockeying for the for the pole position
and their denunciations and
prescriptions
it was hmm what's the word
extraordinary we all know that Vladimir
Putin is holding something over Donald
Trump we do not know what it is but we
know it must be something extraordinary
I would say actually what if the
definition it meets is the first word of
the impeachment article in the
Constitution which is treason bribery
and high crimes and misdemeanors we
don't know whether what we're seeing is
dementia psychopathy compromised but
what we're seeing is extraordinary do
they all get together and pick this is
the multisyllabic word we're gonna use
today
extraordinary you know what's
extraordinary the high dudgeon responses
to what was essentially an error of
communication the President reiterated
his support of his Intel community and
he tried to clarify his comments on
Tuesday well then there was this from a
cabinet meeting today which began with
an unfortunate mini ad lib no president
ever as tough as I have been on Russia I
think President Putin knows that better
than anybody certainly a lot better than
the media he understands it and he's not
happy about it and he shouldn't be happy
about it because there's never been a
president as tough on Russia as I have
been okay when he said no that little no
you can hardly hear that only through
kerosene on the media fire which in turn
lit up today's press briefing do you
have any sense why the president has not
been more critical of Putin why won't he
criticize why wasn't he critical an
approved actions
why should this president have any
credibility to Americans in what he says
they love the media figures talking
about someone else's credibility at this
point the president's offhand remarks
were let's face it some self-inflicted
wounds but the rabid media Democrats the
neo cons the never Trump errs they hope
to turn that little Nick into a mortal
blow and now they're just making no
sense at all we are in a 911
national emergency because our country
is under attack issue a subpoena not
only for the translator and the notes
but also for the national security team
if they don't drag the translator in
they have to find out the answers from
the Secretary of State but they have to
find that answers out for not only
ambassador McColl but but what else was
discussed in that meeting it's
frightening rewrite the Constitution and
have another president take over right
now oh my god people actually get paid
to say things like that
it is stunning okay okay gonna get right
out in there rewriting the Constitution
part mounting an overthrow of a duly
elected president
you kind of start hearing the rumblings
of that there the left has no record to
run on certainly not in the midterms
what are they accomplished zero they
can't go to the voters and say this is
our prescription for making your life
better we're gonna bring you to four
percent economic growth this is what
we're gonna do to hold China accountable
and trade this is what we're gonna do to
have a stronger border they want to
abolish ice for goodness sakes so what
they do is they seek to create another
narrative that the president is somehow
like secretly working behind closed
doors to advance Russia's agenda and
that he's at odds with his own
intelligence chiefs this is patently
absurd and I think they know it is now
granted the president has occasionally
been inartful in the way he's explained
his position sometimes his frustration
with the muller investigation has gotten
the better of him but when you cut
through all the theatrical displays of
outraged trump in many ways is saying
what he's always said even if no one
wants to hear him out I'll go along with
Russia it could have been China it could
have been a lot of different routes I
think well could have been Russia but I
think it could well on the next screen
you already know what it's gonna have
said have been other countries Donald
Trump in his heart of hearts is not
convinced that Russia meddled in the
election take a breath Chris that's not
what he said historically or this week
the president is saying that Russia is
responsible for meddling and that they
are not alone now I'm the first to call
the president out when he's imprecise in
his language and he has been
communications are vital
important on a matter as important as
this especially with this Muller cloud
that continues to hang over his head but
saying that Russia is not the only
foreign powers seeking a tamper with our
elections caused havoc in our society is
neither treasonous nor erroneous in fact
it is correct just listen to the
Director of National Security
damned codes every day foreign actors
the worst offenders being Russia China
Iran and North Korea every day they are
penetrating our digital infrastructure
and conducting a range of cyber
intrusions and attacks against targets
in the United States you hear that
Russia is one of many foreign actors
trying to disrupt things in the United
States across the board every day
incoming from these other countries that
does not rule out the presence of other
foreign actors but perhaps the most
egregious in revealing of all the
lunatic get them in the rubber room
reactions regarding Trump Russia once
again comes from the former CIA chief
John Brennan the man I'm sorry to say I
know it sounds uncharitable is a
complete embarrassment spewing
outrageous falsehoods while offering
reckless advice would there be a
tendency for intelligence gatherers
briefers to withhold now some vital
intelligence to the president there very
well might be there might be out of
concern he went on to expand on that but
yeah out of concern that the White House
of the president what would would run to
Sergey Lavrov her or Putin himself think
about that this is the guy who headed up
the CIA
by the way the same one I believe who
signed off on the unmasking without a
warrant he's essentially urging current
Intel officers or giving basically tacit
approval to they're concealing key
national security information from the
country's current commander-in-chief
shame on you sir that is tantamount to a
slow-rolling
so we've gone from charges of treason
within minutes of frankly of what
President Trump said in Helsinki to
calls for resignations to now former
Intel Chiefs encouraging traitorous acts
acts against the current duly elected
president of the United States it is
stunning the next time you pundits and
hosts want to see a disgraceful and
extraordinary at treasonous moment just
pull up some of your TV appearances on
the DVR and hit play and that's the
angle